Some say that SCP-2102 was a mistake, an abomination
created by an accident of medical science.
Maybe those people are right, maybe there’s
much more to it than that.
Either way, they don’t know the full story.
How could they?
They weren’t there all the way back in 1972.
But Doctor Pavel Zukal was.
The earliest moments, the events that directly
preceded SCP-2102’s creation began on March
2nd.
The wind was carrying an unforgiving, freezing
bite with it as Zukal made his way to the
Institute of Experimental Medicine ČSAV in
Czechoslovakia.
With the Cold War between the USSR and the
United States underway, there was already
an air of secrecy on both sides.
Espionage and intelligence-gathering operations
were rampant, bringing with them paranoia
and distrust.
There was no way of knowing if someone was
a double agent leaking information to the
West.
But while the governments of Russia, America,
and their various respective allies and enemies
scrambled for control and amassed obscene
quantities of nuclear arms in secret, there
were even more cogs turning, hidden in the
deepest, darkest shadows.
The SCP Foundation’s long-standing rivalry
with various other Groups of Interest was
well-known among any with a high enough security
clearance.
Most of these groups were radicals or outliers;
despite possessing knowledge of anomalies
or even being directly linked to them, a lot
of GOIs were independent of any world government.
But, for decades, the Foundation had been
aware of a directly competing establishment,
effectively a parallel of their own organization
on the other side of the globe.
They were known as GRU Division P, a USSR
equivalent of the SCP Foundation themselves.
It's unclear, based on what was recovered
from Doctor Zukal’s personal diary, if he
had been directly scouted by GRU Division
P for their project in Czechoslovakia.
Given the air of secrecy engulfing the USSR
at the time, it’s possible that Pavel himself
had no inclination that Division P was even
involved in the project due to take place
at the Institute of Experimental Medicine.
He might have suspected, but with no way of
knowing for sure.
Similarly, there was no way Zukal could have
known what the project would lead…
what he’d have a hand in creating.
The initial few weeks after his arrival at
the Institute were rocky, to say the least.
Zukal, along with a team of scientists and
technicians working on orders direct from
Moscow, had to contend with unreliable equipment
and difficulty getting electricity to power
the project.
Eventually, after clearing those initial hurdles,
testing could begin.
But what was the goal of this mysterious project?
Well, through Zukal, GRU Division P and the
Kremlin were chasing something the scientific
world has been trying to accomplish for decades.
Something that could change the very landscape
of not only the Cold War but the entirety
of modern medicine: the secrets of cellular
regeneration.
Unlocking that would, in theory, enable them
to create the world’s very first unkillable
super-soldier - and hey, it definitely wouldn’t
be the craziest secret operation carried out
by a world superpower during the Cold War.
The CIA spent millions turning a cat into
a listening device and training it to infiltrate
enemy headquarters.
This so-called “Acoustic Kitty” was struck
and killed by a random van during its first
mission.
Compared to that, a cell-regenerating super
soldier was positively sensible.
With a worldwide nuclear arms race already
underway, perhaps the project’s ultimate
goal was to produce an entire army of these
self-regenerating troops.
With something like that in their hands, the
USSR would have the manpower to reinforce
their nuclear arsenal, and potentially even
soldiers capable of surviving and healing
from the effects of an atomic blast.
On the fifth of May 1972, the first of the
project’s human test subjects began to show
promising results.
They underwent physical trauma at the hands
of Zukal and the other scientists, only for
their bodies to react much faster than the
ordinary healing process would allow.
Rapid clotting took place in the affected
areas, preventing the subjects from bleeding
out.
However, this quickly went awry, the clots
turning into severe lesions.
Realizing this had occurred thanks to Michail
– one of the other project scientists – administering
too much neodymium, Zukal chastised his colleague,
vowing to drag him to Moscow personally if
another mistake like that ever took place
again.
Unfortunately, by the last few days of June,
Doctor Zukal and his team were no closer to
success; every subject that underwent testing
succumbed to the same necrosis.
Reducing the amount of neodymium had only
made the reaction worse, something Pavel couldn’t
allow Michail to know without the risk of
it being held over his head for the remainder
of the project.
In every instance, the doctors were able to
trigger rapid cell division, fifty times faster
than that which occurs in the ordinary healing
process of human beings.
But the biggest drawback was that this division
would quickly become uncontrollable.
It was creating enough new matter on a cellular
level, that it would choke each test subject
in its own excess waste.
As you might expect, Doctor Zukal noted in
his diary that this process wasn’t a pretty
sight.
Come mid-August 1972, the project scientists
decided they needed a test subject with more
resilience than the average person, and a
suitable candidate was provided.
He was a counter-revolutionary, who had been
sentenced to fifteen years in a uranium mine
as a punishment detail.
Despite such an extended period of time under
the harsh conditions of the mine, and the
close proximity to a radioactive element such
as uranium, the man managed to survive unscathed.
Upon closer examination, this new guinea pig
– referred to as X-16 – had a rate of
healing twice as fast as that of the average
man.
Perhaps it was a random genetic abnormality
that made X-16 this way, or maybe it was a
result of his extensive time in the uranium
mines.
Either way, it made him the perfect new subject
for Zukal’s experiments.
Initially, Subject X-16’s preliminary testing
results looked promising, the wound healing
process was actually taking place now, instead
of resulting in necrosis or aborting as it
had with the earlier experiments.
In fact, Doctor Zukal seemed to think X-16
was healing almost too quickly.
But, nevertheless, testing continued.
Although not without a different type of problem.
The questionable morality of what they were
doing began to set in for Pavel, causing him
nights of endless tossing and turning, unable
to sleep as he reflected on what he’d done.
X-16 had managed to survive for much longer
than the earlier test subjects, but it was
clear that the torture this man had to endure
was exacting a heavy toll.
Every day, the doctors would lacerate him,
time and time again, recording the results.
And every day, he survived, only for the cycle
to begin again the next day.
For his own part, Zukal was conflicted.
On the one hand, the results of the testing
were proving successful, lasting far longer
and working far more effectively than they
had in the past.
And yet, on the other, it came at the cost
of one man’s continued suffering.
To make matters worse, Pavel had no way of
voicing his concerns to any of his team.
Any questioning of his orders or the project’s
methods would have been viewed by GRU Division
P and the KGB as sedition and treason, earning
the good doctor a one-way ticket to a gulag
or, if he was lucky, a clean shot to the back
of the head from an agent’s pistol.
Often, morality is sacrificed for the greater
good, in the pursuit of the advancement of
science or a nation’s goals.
But, now that the project was showing results
with X-16, now that it was real, what they
were doing still weighed heavily on Doctor
Zukal’s conscience.
Then, on October 15th, 1972, the final piece
of the puzzle seemed to become clear.
By introducing the correct amount of a stabilizing
agent into the serum they had concocted, Zukal
and his team had perfected the composition.
Upon administering this newly completed version
of the solution, the doctor noted in his diary
that Subject X-16 was responding well.
At least, medically the subject was responding
well.
It was clear that the continuous experimentation
he had been subjected to was causing uncooperative
behavior in X-16.
But, so close to the cusp of achieving the
project’s goals, Doctor Zukal was quick
to cast aside his previous doubts about the
ethics of their methods.
They were so close to victory, so close to
the project being over, that it no longer
mattered how cooperative X-16 was being.
But, two weeks and four days later, just as
the project was nearing its end goal, disaster
struck.
MU Doctor Elena Oravcova was one of the scientists
on Zukal’s team, who had primarily helped
when examining the early cell divisions, those
that were leading to necrosis and causing
test subjects to produce too much excessive
genetic material.
Elena had made a startling discovery and immediately
brought it to Doctor Zukal in a distraught
show of panic.
The cell samples they had used to test their
serum were now gaining mass, seemingly from
nowhere.
Just like the earlier experiments, the effects
were working almost too well, causing an overabundance
of cellular regeneration to the point where
the cells couldn’t stop producing masses
of waste genetic material.
When Zukal brought Elena’s findings to Doctor
Szilard and one Jurij T. Fedenko – the project
heads assigned by Division P – they were
quick to disregard it as an error, determined
to press on with the project to meet their
deadline.
Over the course of the following weeks, up
to late November, Zukal was trying to determine
what was causing this change.
It was clear that, unless he and Elena could
resolve the issues with the serum, Subject
X-16 would be a total failure.
But time was running out, with their superiors
at GRU Division P and the Kremlin expecting
results by early December.
Under untold amounts of pressure and subsequent
stress, Doctor Pavel Zukal found himself losing
time, unable to sleep to the point he was
drifting off whenever he was on the verge
of a breakthrough.
By the end, Elena was the only member of the
team trying to help him methodically figure
out what had gone wrong.
The deadline for the project arrived on December
2nd, 1972.
Pavel didn’t sleep all night leading up
to it, knowing he would have to present a
functioning super soldier to GRU Division
P. In the best case, he was risking being
accused of negligent failure, forced to restart
the project from scratch, making his months
of hard work redundant.
But, worst-case scenario, Zukal could be charged
with treason for having not completed the
task he was selected for.
On the second of December, he wrote:
“I really do not know which is better.
Eh, tomorrow is a day too.”
Nobody knows if Doctor Pavel Zukal lived to
see that tomorrow; his final diary entry was
made on the day SCP-2102 was born.
For months, the SCP Foundation had operatives
embedded within the Czechoslovakian government,
as part of innumerable Cold War espionage
gathering efforts.
During that time, their agents had gathered
enough intelligence to make the Foundation
aware of a GRU Division P project based at
the Institute of Experimental Medicine, and
that the scientists there were looking to
unlock the secret of rapid cellular regeneration.
Someone, possibly even one of Zukal’s team,
had managed to infiltrate the project and
had leaked documents to the SCP Foundation,
explaining what was going on in Czechoslovakia.
The plan was that the Foundation would move
in – in secret, of course – to extract
and contain test subject X-16 in January of
1973.
That day would never come to fruition though.
On the second of December, only a month before
they had planned to act, the Foundation became
aware of a catastrophe occurring at the Institute
of Experimental Medicine.
One of their agents in Czechoslovakia alerted
them to a disturbance that had caused civilians
and scientists alike to run from the Institute
in fear for their lives.
Something had gotten loose, and the Foundation
had to act fast.
Luckily, a reconnaissance team was stationed
in Eastern Europe, members of various Mobile
Task Forces who had been spying on GRU Division
P and the rest of the USSR.
Moving quickly, the recon team was deployed
to Czechoslovakia.
Led by a field commander named Merrick, they
were given the objective to determine the
cause of the situation and, if possible, recover
its anomalous source.
Merrick and the recon team arrived on-site
at the Institute’s grounds.
The entrance to the bunker which had been
housing the project was left wide open, with
not a soul in sight.
As the team progressed further, Merrick couldn’t
help but notice a pungent smell permeating
the labs and offices that they passed.
Foundation Command urged their operatives
to proceed cautiously, and recover any paperwork
they could.
Among the logistical documents was a diary,
belonging to one of the scientists; although
the name ‘Pavel Zukal’ on the cover was
no longer legible, forever lost.
The further he and the other MTF agents progressed,
the worse the smell got.
They located an elevator, deciding to take
it down to the lower levels of the bunker.
One by one, the team filed in, Merrick radioing
Command.
“Command, any seismic activity in this area?”
he asked.
“Not that we know of, Merrick,” came the
Foundation’s reply.
“Why?”
“I think I just felt something move down
there…”
The elevator had barely descended a foot before
it hit something, stopping it in an instant.
As Merrick tried once again to contact Foundation
Command, that same something came tearing
through the elevator floor.
Over the radio, the SCP Foundation were treated
to a cacophony of screeching, tearing metal,
along with the screams of their own men.
What Merrick and his team had encountered
may have once been a man, perhaps someone
subjected to cruelty and torture.
But now, all they saw was an amorphous, fleshy
mass.
Immediately, the recon team opened fire, engaging
what they assumed was a raging monster.
It probably never occurred to them it might
have just wanted to be free, after years of
imprisonment, followed by months of horrendous
experiments.
Minutes later, Merrick was able to get in
contact with Command again, locked in a heated
battle with the entity.
But every round fired, every shot their guns
landed, nothing was having any effect.
Whenever Merrick dealt damage to the creature,
part of it seemed to grow, faster and faster
each time.
Their guns were useless, unable to stop the
expanding, monstrous test subject.
Even grenades thrown by the MTF operatives,
causing multiple explosions, did little to
stop the entity in its tracks.
Listening in over the radio, knowing they
had few options left, the SCP Foundation dispatched
a pair of F-4 Phantoms, long-range supersonic
fighter jets, equipped with a payload of M47A1
Napalm Incendiary bombs.
With Merrick and his men almost on the ropes,
Command issued an order to retreat.
They fled the bunker, only to feel the ground
shake beneath their feet; the monster had
breached the topsoil, still coming after them.
Jones – one of the Foundation’s agents
– was pulled under the encroaching shapeless
mass, crushed to death as it continued its
pursuit.
Utterly horrified at the sight and speed of
the creature, Merrick started begging Command
over the radio to get its fighter jets to
the scene.
Six minutes later, the sound of twin turbine
engines shot through the air, followed by
the whistle of bombs careening down towards
the ground.
In a second, Merrick, his team, and the creature
were engulfed in a fiery explosion, the heat
proving enough to cauterize the fleshy abomination’s
expanding tissue.
Ever since December 1972, the entity now designated
as SCP-2102 has been housed at Site-122, contained
by the SCP Foundation.
They keep it in a modified cell, restrained
at all times with its hands and feet in padded
sleeves.
This is done in order to prevent the risk
of injury, either accidental or intentional
given both SCP-2102’s anomalous properties,
and its self-destructive tendencies.
Its body is covered in scars, both from its
previous escape attempts – back when it
was known as Subject X-16 – and from burns
from the F-4 Phantom’s napalm payload.
These particular injuries seared the entity’s
ears, mouth and eyes closed, rendering it
deaf, mute, and blind.
If SCP-2102 ever suffers any form of external
injury, its anomalous properties will trigger.
The creature, as you might have guessed, possessed
an advanced form of cellular healing, able
to regenerate from all wounds inflicted on
it.
However, the process was never perfected.
It still works too well, so well that SCP-2102’s
cells don’t know when to stop.
Instead, they continue producing bodily tissue,
expanding its mass into every available space
without a halt.
The process can be slowed if an obstacle is
introduced, boxing in the exponentially growing
tissue.
However, any object – or person – in its
path is eventually crushed under the mounting
pressure.
At present, the Foundation still has no idea
how much SCP-2102’s tissue could expand,
potentially even posing a risk to the entire
world if left unchecked.
There is only one sure-fire way to stop the
creature’s healing; it can only be halted
by cauterizing the open wound with intense
heat.
It’s literally a sure-fire solution.
SCP-2102 is a result of the good Doctor Zukal’s
work, combined with his and GRU Division P’s
willingness to put aside their morality.
They didn’t create an undying, regenerating
super-soldier for the USSR as they had intended.
Instead, all they accomplished was turning
a tortured man into a monster, an abomination
endlessly tormented by the experiments performed
on him.
Not quite as useful on the battlefield, is
it?
Now go check out “SCP-049 THE PLAGUE DOCTOR”
and “SCP-847 THE MANNEQUIN” for more stories
of medically macabre monstrosities sure to
make your blood run cold.